aujourd'hui je me trouve à Versailles
dans quelques jours se déroule le Mois
Molière le top départ c'est jeudi 1er
juin à la grande écurie du château de
Versailles le Mois Molière c'est le
rendez-vous culturel phare de l'été pour
en parler nous sommes avec François
demazieres bonjour alors vous êtes le
maire de Versailles mais également le
créateur du Mois Molière première
question cette année combien il y aura
de représentations durant tout le mois à
Versailles c'est difficile de vous
recommande précisément c'est le moins
Molière c'est devenu un très gros
festival sans doute après le festival
d'Avignon auquel incomparable parce que
c'est vraiment la grande rencontre
quasimentale du théâtre le Mois Molière
doit se situer très dans les tous plus
gros festival après celui-ci il y aura
je pense dans la programmation
officielle il y a beaucoup de création
ce qui est important et dans la
programmation dit amateur là le nombre
des spectacles également fort
autour de 300 350 spectacles et alors
ces spectacles investissent des lieux
phares comme la grande écurie du château
mais aussi des lieux un peu plus
insolites les parcs les rues les
spectacles sont au sein des quartiers
c'est ça qui fait aussi la beauté de cet
événement oui le principe si vous voulez
c'est vraiment la culture qui va vers
tout le monde donc ça a été l'origine de
ce qu'on a voulu ce que j'ai voulu quand
j'ai créé ce festival c'était qu'on
aille facilement qui est pas la barrière
de l'argent notamment donc les
spectacles sont dans les quartiers et la
tradition la commedia del arte aussi la
comédie a delarte qui a inspiré
finalement le théâtre de Molière et nous
avons ici l'Académie Internationale du
théâtre dirigé par Carnot Bozo a
beaucoup de troubles donc souvent ce
sont ces troubles qui vont dans les
quartiers et puis comme vous le disiez
il y a des lieux phares notamment la
cour arrière des grandes écuries de
Château de Versailles qu'un très beau
lieu
qui est très simple c'est un mur
historique et cette cour a une belle
sonorité on met en face un gradin de 640
places cette année gradins est neuf je
le dis à tous les habitudes du Mois
Molière ils vont voir une transformation
les assises sont plus agréables et donc
une succession de spectacles va se
dérouler à l'intérieur et puis vous avez
évidemment d'autres lieux vous pensez à
toute la programmation musicale c'est un
festival non seulement de théâtre mais
aussi une musique et la musique elle est
partout elle est aussi dans les églises
car il y a beaucoup de chorales de très
grande qualité à Versailles elle est au
Conservatoire de Versailles elle est
également dans des salles privées de
théâtre etc etc
[Musique]
et alors quelle est la ligne conductrice
de cette année de cette édition 2023
c'est des spectacles de création de
compagnie des gens reconnus si vous
voulez qui vont aller ensuite à Avignon
présenter leur spectacle ces spectacles
sont vendus à Avignon et ensuite il
tourne dans toute la France j'aime
l'esprit de troupes donc c'est ça que
l'on met en avant mais c'est il y a
quelques solos c'est la mode aujourd'hui
pendant les enfants financières il y a
beaucoup plus de spectacles sont des
waman shoes c'est pas tellement ce que
j'essaye de mettre en avant sauf le
spectacle en particulier c'est plutôt au
contraire spectacle où vous avez
vraiment l'esprit du théâtre
c'est-à-dire avec des troupes Éric
Bouvron qui fera l'ouverture et
quelqu'un qui fait ses créations ici
justement on va parler de l'ouverture de
cette 27e édition braconnier ce sera aux
grandes écuries est-ce que que nous en
parler un petit peu plus de ce spectacle
de cette pièce oui alors toutes les
créations sont intéressantes honnêtement
et
braconnier je l'ai mis en ouverture
parce que effectivement on a une sorte
de fidélité avec certains metteurs c'est
le cas avec Eric avec Bouvron
Eric un cursus personnel assez
passionnant c'était qu'il est par son
père il est sud-africain par sa mère il
est grecque et en fait il travaille en
français depuis des années et il a
développé une écriture très inspirée
d'ailleurs des canevas américains donc
c'est 200 des histoires mais aussi avec
cette capacité qu'il a connaissant bien
les cultures du monde et bien d'amener
des musiques qu'on entend rarement en
France et ça donne des univers et il a
eu pour les cavaliers qui sait qu'il a
monté il y a maintenant quatre ans le
Molière du meilleur spectacle de théâtre
privé ce qui est vraiment la plus haute
qu'on pense des Molières dans le privé
il y a aussi
sur le thème à rentrer
42 entre 40 ans et la rentrée scolaire
42 dans certains quartiers de Paris
notamment le 11e arrondissement et bien
trois quarts des invités pas là parce
que tout simplement c'était suite à la
race du Valdy et ses enfants n'étaient
plus là
nous avons beaucoup d'étrangers Grimbert
zuloski Cohen
et bien mesdames
alors
la directrice non mais c'est incroyable
c'est insensé nous sommes en guerre
Madame la Directrice toutes les
possibles tous les accents sont-ils ou
pas du quartier et attendez c'est pas
fini ouais voilà
je continue pourquoi tout de suite
parler de rafle et d'abord quelle rafle
quelle preuve avez-vous
c'est comme un
océan
mais en continuant à enseigner nous
résistons au pouvoir tous les opposants
au régime sont arrêtés rejoins-nous
Gisèle
deux octobre 1942 fera date dans les
arnaques de l'éducation nationale sans
neuf petite fille de l'école Victor Hugo
n'arriveront jamais
[Musique]
mais vous avez d'autres spectacles je
pourrai vous citer à la façon de le
reste de l'oreille spectacle sur des
tensions de tangos là aussi on est en
rapport avec l'histoire de la guerre
parce que c'était un frère ou une sœur
c'est une histoire vraie c'est un vrai
un seul qui était des danseuses de tango
très simple des années 30 elle va
disparaître elle va être tuée en fait
par les nazis si vous voulez et lui va
continuer tout seul et continuons en
souvenir de sa seuil il va se
transformer il va danser comme une femme
en fait si vous voulez c'est une soirée
et bien merci beaucoup François
Demazières d'avoir accepté de répondre à
nos questions le moment Molière ça
commence le 1er juin et ça se termine le
2 juillet aux grandes écuries avec la
représentation de la pièce Le Médecin
malgré lui vous retrouverez toute la
programmation sur le site internet moi
molière.com